- [Narrator] Tucked away in the depths
of Siberia is a the town of Mirny,
a cityscape dominated by a
massive hole in the ground.
(electronic music)
This open pit was once
a thriving diamond mine.
Mirny was one of the fist places diamonds
were found in Russia.
The Mir mine is about 1,700 feet deep
and is one of the largest
mines in the world.
While the mine is now closed, it stands
as a testament to the
small town's perseverance
against the harsh Siberian winters.
Building the mine was a difficult task.
It took seven years of
miners battling winters
for seven months out of the year.
With temperatures hitting below freezing,
digging was nearly impossible
in the frozen ground.
With this historic
landmark, the small town's
record-breaking mine
reminds its inhabitants
that they are still a
diamond in the rough.
(digital effect)